[Music]
welcome back to Las Vegas now today we
have a special treat from our own
cooking confidence coach Nanny Bubby
thanks to Chapman Automotive the
sponsors of this segment this time
you're going to her kitchen where she'll
share a special dish that you can make
at home this holiday season
a lot can be said about going through a
home remodel especially when you're
going from brown to White from walls
right down to the studs that you can see
from walls to dust all the way to
building it back well here we are right
here in this fabulous new kitchen the
big reveal here is the finished Nanny
Bubby kitchen and nothing is making me
more thrilled and more happy and tearing
up both of us to have Don Hamrick from
Chapman Automotive our sponsor to be
here today so hey you ready to make a
butterboard for Thanksgiving it's a
beautiful setting to make it in yes
thank you and it has been our tradition
now three years in a row to do the
Thanksgiving show together so we have to
keep that going we will so butterboards
are the latest and greatest you said
your daughter is making one for
Thanksgiving so excited she's going to
learn from this okay so here we go you
want to use the beautiful pink heart yes
yes we're going to spread butter like
love because we spread love like butter
and we're going to start out just taking
a dollop of the butter like this and
just spreading it on the board and then
going in afterwards and just making
divots right just like you do on the
golf course
big difference you've seen me play yeah
so go ahead and do that here I'll help
you get it off thank you okay and then
I'll spread it you make the heart-shaped
divots okay okay ready
okay I got it now just go and what you
want to do there you go is you want
interspersum
so they're going to catch all this stuff
yeah that's correct okay now we're going
to take a drizzle of honey look at that
look how perfect that is good job with
the heart that's how to have heart you
gotta have heart you gotta and we're
just gonna drizzle the honey
I know can you believe this beautiful is
that gorgeous or what just a little bit
more and now a couple of dollops of fig
Jam okay so what I'm gonna do is I'll
dollop it on and you sort of squeeze it
in with your beautiful little heart
the spoon shaped like a beautiful heart
maybe even a little tushy I like that
that comment do I say that on the air
are they going to beat me out there you
go okay and then next that's it right
into the divots that's it okay now the
marcona almonds beautiful
followed by the pomegranate seeds which
I will hand to you and you can drizzle
those right on
right after the almonds oh my gosh this
is so incredible and then look at that
color so now we've got some competing or
transitional flavors we're going to use
rosemary here because it gives it like
the feeling or the taste of the earth
you love that that beautiful Rosemary a
little bit of thyme what I really love
is that we're going to take these chives
and we're going to I mean chives with
the butter and the sweet and the honey
and the Fig amazing right I'm gonna
finish it with some leaves of sage which
I'll let you pull off like this there we
go
foreign
ful edible flowers that we're going to
stick in like that look at that it just
keeps getting better doesn't it I mean
is that beautiful or what so you can
make these the day before pop them in
the fridge afterwards and they are
perfect for when your guests arrive for
Thanksgiving and you could do the swirl
of butter
put it in the fridge and then five
minutes before you serve it put
everything on it and it's like the way
that is a butterboard for Thanksgiving
now here's the best part these are your
sides these are what you're going to put
into it you're going to either scoop it
up with carrots crackers a brioche toast
and my favorite go ahead and dip in
and radishes really the radish with this
is incredible but here is dig in
this is a whole grain cranberry toast
warm what do you think you did beautiful
yep I'm never leaving oh we're just down
should we say spread love life better
for Thanksgiving I should spread love
like our Mouse
I'm getting there go out and spread love
like butter Happy Thanksgiving everybody
oh
uh
thank you to Chapman Automotive for
sponsoring this segment and check out
Nanny puppy's kitchen and Garden on
social media and online at
nannybubby.com Rocky